[Music]
we've been given a death sentence we
thought police in a crime everybody
would think it's either too much money
oh my gosh the gates kids get that much
mayor that's all the gates kids get we
have you the hospital a nation
congratulations on the purchase McCrory
has begun into a blood scandal described
as the worst treatment disaster in the
history of the NHS nearly 3,000 people
died after receiving products infected
with hepatitis and HIV in the 70s and
80s tony was a child when he lost his
dad and both his uncle's to HIV
contracted during treatment for
hemophilia around about 1984 my father
became unwell
I was removed from the family home and
sent to live with my mother that
relationship didn't work out I didn't
really know her
my mother wrung my father back up to
basically say I had to go home which is
at the point where he told her what was
wrong I was still unaware of that I was
12 years old I was then placed into a
local Children's Home at the age of 12 I
was there for about a year and then my
14th birthday came and my father came to
visit have a nice day out went away and
he came back a week later with my
brothers we went off down to her to a
family room with in the children's home
that I was in where he then told me he
was HIV positive
I think straight away I knew straight
away that was it
front-page headlines of of a gay plague
people were dying there was no there was
no cure it was a death sentence the last
time I saw my father was in April 19
six and I never saw him again after that
he died on the 22nd of September which
was this weekend so he's been dead now
for 32 years and shortly within a matter
of weeks of his death my father's
brother was diagnosed with HIV
he died in 2002 my father's eldest
brother or older brother was also
diagnosed with hepatitis C in 1990 on
Christmas Eve because of the hemophilia
being hereditary
and you'll find this across the board
with lots of other families that there
wasn't just one person you know in some
families there were six or seven if
there were a big family of brothers or
big family that had the hemophilia in
the majority of hemophiliacs at that
time I think somewhere in the region of
about 93 or 94 percent of the population
of hemophiliacs at that time were
infected so it pretty much wiped out or
will wipe out a whole generation of
hemophiliacs Michelle was infected with
hepatitis C by a blood transfusion given
during childbirth I had my first son in
September 1997 and hemorrhaged and
needed four pints of blood I needed to
have the blood it was as simple as that
then in 1991 I had a set of twins and I
needed a further two units of blood in
the mid-90s there was some form of
advertisement on the TV saying that the
Bloods hadn't been screened before a
certain date and several pointer factors
so if your dad some tattoos dentistry
blood transfusions etc it'd be worth
popping along to your GP just to get
checked out so which I dutifully did I
found the helpline number received a
call to the magazine down and went along
to see my GP explained that I've been
excessively tired
most of the feeling very well and
explained about that I'd had the two
separate blood transfusions after the
children were born and all direction I
got from a GP was or if you've got four
children what to expect of course you're
going to be tired and don't be silly
hepatitis E and sent me on my way as a
young mum I look to my professional with
trust and belief that I actually
wouldn't have it and it was 21 years
later by a chance at a different GP
surgery that and we found out I had
hepatitis C which has left me with
cirrhosis and untold and health
complications and problems we've been
given a death sentence without being
without commenting upon
[Music]
there's concern for air well that's been
spotted in the River Thames in Kent the
RSPCA says the beluga is swimming
strongly in feeding but the species is
usually found too in cooler waters
the whale is out of area there's only
been 20 previous sightings in UK waters
of beluga whales the last being three
years ago off the coast of
Northumberland so there is the potential
that something is wrong there's also the
potential that it's not it does seem to
be swimming strongly at the moment and
we're told it's only a couple of metres
long which suggests it's probably a baby
they can males can grow up to five and a
half metres females a little bit smaller
because it is out of area and we
obviously don't have much experience
with it it's really hard to give an
estimate on what age it might be at this
stage and as far as we know it's fine
it's been feeding it's in the Thames
where it shouldn't be when do we start
getting worried that it's getting
himself into real trouble there's a few
indicators that might suggest
something's wrong a body condition havea
obviously if it looks like it's coming
into you're close to shore with the risk
of stranding or if it does strand then
obviously we're gonna be concerned which
is why we're monitoring it very closely
at this stage and why is a beluga whale
that should be in the Arctic halfway up
with temps it's really hard to speculate
there's many reasons why any animal
comes into an area where it shouldn't be
it could be that it's simply young and
lost it might be that something's going
on medically with it or with another
animal they came in with if there is one
we haven't seen or heard of any other
sightings of any other individuals
it could be something centipede with its
coordination and
under water or above land and lots of
things can affect it which is why we
urge the public and anyone on a boat
wall in the air on a helicopter or plane
to not get too close because again not
in itself can affect its behavior and
could start to push it in the wrong
direction hello good afternoon to you
Jeremy Corbyn Jeremy Corbyn Jeremy
Corbyn so recall being Jeremy Corbyn
gentlemen thank you for joining us
simple question is brexit going to
happen on the 29th of March 2019 at the
moment it looks like it and we will
challenge this government on the six
tests and if they don't meet them then
we will vote against it to be clear it
might not happen on the 29th of March
well given the policy that you're
putting forward our policies are to
protect jobs and living standards and to
ensure that the regulations on workers
rights consumer rights the environment
are met in any agreement that was made
with Europe and therefore we've set
these six tests down and in Parliament
we will vote accordingly to those six
tests but if they don't meet the six
tests and other hurdles are not met and
we'll vote against him and brexit might
not happen when it's currently jus under
law in March 29 we will then vote
against it if it doesn't meet our six
tests and the government would then have
to go back to the European Union and
continue negotiations or they might
choose to resign have a general election
as the people of this country we decide
who they want to conduct these the best
[Applause]
Teresa may joined world leaders in New
York this week for the 73rd UN General
Assembly when I spoke to her I asked her
about brexit about the possibility of an
early general election and whether she
backs guy News's campaign to have an
independent commission to get debates
head of the next German election prime
minister if as you are saying you
believe that you can get a deal and you
believe that when they look the deal in
the face in the moment that MPs will
come around to believing it is the right
option for the United Kingdom if they
don't do that however are there any
circumstances where you believe it would
be in the national interest to call
another general elections I what I'm
working for is a good deal I'm working
to bring that good deal back from Europe
and I believe at that you just rule it
out before March - yeah
as I've said what I'm working for is a
good deal we're putting the effort in
we're set out the issues in which we
believe the European Union should
respond very clearly if they've got
concerns with the proposal we've put
forward let's hear those concerns it is
not in the national interest to have a
general election we're working in the
national interest for the right
relationship with Europe in the future
Sky News is running a campaign to make
debates happen all the other party
leaders have signed up to the creation
the idea of a creation of an independent
commission to organize and run televised
debates ahead of a general election will
you support that proposal the next
general election is in 2022 there's
plenty of time to think about those
issues that's what we're focused on now
is actually ensuring that we're working
to get that good deal from the European
Union
Melinda Gates is one of the world's most
formidable philanthropists along with
her husband Bill Gates who set up
Microsoft she's trying to end extreme
poverty around the world I caught up
with her here in New York City and asked
her how she's trying to do that we are
in partnership with many many
governments around the world the UK
government included France Germany
Norway many African governments the
Indian government to try and work on
some of the very specific goals that is
we work on bringing down maternal
mortality we bring down childhood
mortality one of the greatest things
that have happened because the previous
goals set by the United Nations the
Millennium Development Goals
is that really childhood mortality that
is the number of deaths of children
under the age of five has been cut in
half since 1990 in half that is huge
progress as a world I was speaking to
one of your colleagues earlier who was
pointed out to me that the population in
places like Nigeria is going to be
higher than what it is in the United
States we need to really pay attention
to the youth population and the growing
number of youth on the continent of
Africa and it hangs in the balance if we
help them lift themselves up there's
unbelievable potential there for them to
change their countries and their
continent but however if we don't make
the investments the world has made in
the past around vaccines or malarial bed
nets or other tools then they're gonna
stay in poverty and we're gonna have
more people in poverty than we've had in
the past and so we want to make sure
that the world goes towards the youth
potential can we talk briefly about your
children
sure do they do they want to follow in
your footsteps so the thing that bill
and I have encouraged all three of our
children to do we have two daughters in
a sign-in date is to follow their own
dreams and their own potential so
they're still figuring out what they
want to do we have a daughters out of
college a son who just entered college
and another daughter who's in secondary
school so we'll see what they want to do
what sort of support D I mean a comment
was it was it mr. Buffett who said that
he wasn't or was it Zuckerberg who said
that he wasn't going to leave any of his
money to his children he was
they had to continue on their own path
and make their own way do you do that
with yours so Warren has actually
changed a bit what he's done with his
own children over a time and so I think
those discussions about money are
actually very private inside of a family
and should be kept that way
but I will say this bill and I made
statements that the vast majority of the
resources that have come from Microsoft
will go back to society and I think all
the other discussions about money one of
the things the kids and I talked about
when they were young is they did get an
allowance they had chores they had
allowance and our agreement was between
them and me they were never allowed to
tell anybody else what their allowance
was and neither was I because everybody
would think it's either too much money
oh my gosh the Gates kids get that much
money or that's all the Gates kids get
so I think money discussions amongst a
family should remain private inside a
family well sort of choice did they have
to do oh my gosh they do dishes and take
the garbage out I mean things that other
kids do ladies and gentlemen the
President of the United States Donald J
Trump
[Music]
thank you very much everybody yes go
ahead please
this is the one that was nodding with
every nice thing I said so watch this
question it's a habit of mine how does
all my speeches go with who Hannah
Thomas Peter from Sky News
okay good sky congratulations on the
purchase nothing to do with me I hope
you benefited go ahead are you at all
concerned the message that has been send
it being sent to the women who are
watching this when you use language like
con job in my I think I've used much
worse language in my life than con job
that's like probably the nicest phrase
I've ever used
I mean I'm job it is it's a con job you
know confidence it's a confidence sure
but they should it's a con job I the
Democrats they know it what about the
message they did the same thing with a
Russian investigation they can try to
convince people that I had something to
do with Russia
there was no collusion think of it I'm
in Wisconsin I'm in Michigan I say gee
we're not doing well I won both those
states we're not doing well let me call
the Russians to help does anybody really
believe that it's a con job
Steve Irwin there's a name you never
forget one of Australia's most famous
faces and since he died his family been
working tirelessly to continue his
legacy of conservation and education I'm
delighted to be Owens Terry bindi and
Robert are here we love it here do you
yes I have stopped drinking coffee and
I've taken up tea Oh crocodiles and
snakes still love you there's lots of
squirrels
we don't have squirrels in Australia so
we're loving it yeah gotta say Robert
you're a chip off the old block yeah
very much so
just every day more I remember I was
going through some old photos and I got
a photograph out and said what do you
think of this and he goes that's a photo
of me yeah oh it's not it's a young dad
photo yeah
what's interesting though is that it is
the I mean obviously we knew what Steve
did and and and his passion for nature
what we didn't realize at the time
necessarily was how that was a family
wide sort of venture yes no he was
definitely larger than life and we're
very proud to be carrying on with what
he started its Sherwin was so special is
that to everyone dad was the ultimate
wildlife warrior but to us he was the
greatest dad and to be able to carry on
in his footsteps and make sure that his
legacy lives on forever
is such a blessing part of the beauty of
wildlife is its inherent danger mm-hmm
oh absolutely and I think for for me a
passion that we've always had is really
showing kind of the other side to these
more sort of scary animals things like
crocodiles our apex predators animals
that people see as you know they're just
these mindless hunting killing machines
that's that's not true at all crocodiles
they're my favourite animal and they
really are intelligent creatures they're
great mothers they're very caring
towards one another so really what we're
trying to do is kind of show wildlife in
a different light and show how you can
form this this connection this bond with
each animal and really show just how
amazing and
I'll tell you what you three definitely
make me want to come to Australia's
really want to go to person Terry I've
got to ask you because I mean can't
imagine how difficult it is to lose a
partner and to raise children on your
own and all the all that that entails
Steve would have been so proud of these
two oh I'll say I mean bindi and Robert
ought have been just amazing stepping up
and being passionate about wildlife and
conservation and so respectful of their
dad and his message and mission and to
want to carry on in what he started just
really warms my heart and I couldn't be
more proud of it so I have to say it's
because we have Wonder Woman for a mom I
mean surely about moms strength and and
determination to continue on has been
such an inspiration for us so as a
family dad first came up with the term
wildlife warrior and I really believe
that's who we are we stand up and speak
for those who cannot speak for
themselves
[Music]
Richard gossip is on death row and
Oklahoma
he's had three execution dates all of
being postponed the last because the
prison had been given the wrong drug to
kill him this week he got married to a
woman 33 years his junior who's training
to be an undertaker
I spoke to Leah Jurrasic about what
attracted her to a man who was still
facing execution what on earth is a 21
year old doing and the fact that you can
find out more what Richard gossips case
on my Sky News podcast another dead man
walking
dr. who is one of the longest running
series on British TV hit back with a new
star in the lead role Jodie Whittaker is
the first woman to play the part and I
spoke to her at the show's launch for me
it's been a celebration and a long time
coming and in a moment to go OK you know
it's not that shocking a woman playing
an alien that's that's not the way of it
so I think it's a wonderful time but it
will also be an extraordinary time when
it's when it's and you know we we are
the other half of the population so they
do think I think it's just difficult
change is difficult I think the thing
that you've got to appreciate with the
firm with the fans of the show is that
they you know they have this epic
journey with someone and then the rug is
pulled and it's somebody else and for
some people it can have only ever happen
once because they've fallen in love with
the show with that doctor and it's never
happened before but I think you know
then it's change it is always
nerve-racking but but this show
celebrates it more than any other show
and has done for 50 odd years
[Music]
you